I'm going to start by pointing out that
everything here is on my GitHub repo
under polymorphism Unbound and that
includes the slides so you don't need to
take any notes but you can download from
this if you want to know more about me
you can go to mineviewllc.com
and that will tell you what you need to
know I hope
uh one of the things I do is a podcast
that's their happy path programming we
interview interesting people we think
all right so how did all this start
decades ago when I got started in object
oriented programming after programming
and see an assembly and low-level stuff
I was working at the University of
Washington in the school of oceanography
physical oceanography so basically
physics and we decided to experiment
with this new thing called C plus
and at the time the way that you got C
plus plus is that they mailed you
a tape that looked like this tape
and that's how you loaded it and what
you got was something called seafront
which was a translator from C plus plus
to C not just any c the reason it was C
was because almost every machine out
there at the time at least had a c
compiler but this was before standard C
so seafront had to generate something
that was in this common subset whatever
that was part of this is what got the C
standardization process going so uh what
seafront would do would be it would take
your C plus plus and it would generate
the C code and then you would run that
through your C compiler
and there was so I'm going through
trying to figure this out and there's
really not much at the time to help
figure this out and I come across this
keyword called virtual
and to figure out how virtual work to
set up an example in Virtual you had to
have a base class and you had to inherit
from it and you had to declare the base
virtual so that this weird thing called
Dynamic binding would happen
and this was such an elaborate process
that I came away with the idea that this
is a really fundamental important idea
that we should probably use everywhere
this is this is critical so
um
so so let's do this let's let's just
really Bear Down on the objects and
dynamic binding
so let's look at how we got here
simula was the first object-oriented
language simula 67 so it gives you an
idea it was in the 60s and
simula gives you the idea that it had
something to do with simulation
and so what do you need to do with
simulation you've got a whole bunch of
components representing elements in your
simulation and the one common thing you
need to do is tell each component step
yourself forward in this simulation so
it would be nice if they all had this
kind of common interface which has a few
things that have to do with stepping the
simulation forward they could do
whatever else they want other than that
but that you know the subset of common
interface to help the simulation that
makes sense
so
Small Talk took this idea and ran with
it and it said oh I I like this idea of
objects and sending messages to objects
to tell them what to do and the object
figures out what to do with it that that
all sounds great
um
they added the idea of code reuse
through inheritance so if you have an
object and it does most of what you want
it's like a little Library you can
inherit from it and Tack on some more
operations and the thing about simula or
small talk is that it is inherently
Dynamic similar was was a statically
compiled language but small talk is
inherently Dynamic and by that I mean
that's part of its nature it isn't just
a design choice
and what this means is that in fact the
creators of small talk Allen K in
particular said that he regrets not
calling it message oriented programming
because it was really not so much about
the objects but about this idea that
you're sending messages to the objects
small talk so little messages
and if an object doesn't so you start
with an object you tack on some
functionality to it and you know that
that functionality is there so you send
a message saying do that thing but if
you accidentally send a message to an
object that doesn't know what to do with
it because it hasn't had those
operations added to it it at runtime
comes back and says method not found
so that's a really important aspect of
what object-oriented programming started
at in in small talk and C plus plus took
this idea and they said well we like
this this idea of having some data and
having some operations that that work on
the data and we'll add you know we'll
take this and run with it
and and talk about encapsulation so the
nice thing about that is you've got some
data and it's by default private and
then you've got some operations on that
data and no other operations can
manipulate that data so if the data is
getting out of phase say some somehow
it's getting wonky
you know what operations did that and so
it kind of Narrows your field of
um deduction so you can you can more
easily figure out why is your data
getting into a bad state
so that sounds nice that sounds great
now those of you who are into functional
programming can you know see what's
coming it's like well why not make the
data immutable so then you don't have to
do that but that's not this talk we're
just we're just dealing we're just
dealing with uh with how we got here
um now the nice thing about C plus plus
is you don't have to use objects if you
don't want to you can just do regular
you can just benefit from the things in
C plus plus without messing around with
objects
um
and it is a statically typed language so
it doesn't do the things that small talk
does
and that leads us to Java where they
said well if objects are good then
objects everywhere is the best so we'll
be they model themselves after small
talk and they said all right we want to
do that but we also static typing is
great because it saves all these
problems and you know it has its
benefits so we'll mix the two and that
will be even better and they kind of
lost the idea that the dynamism of small
talk is really an essential part of its
design
um the other thing that was taken from
small talk but didn't really work out
and we'll look at that a little more is
the idea of reusing code through
inheritance which was a selling point
and one that even though I think I made
a very good case for it never really I
was always like really do you want to do
you want to read his code through
inheritance
does that I mean that's what everybody's
saying so I'll go along with it and a
lot of the post-java languages which
we'll look at have learned from the
mistakes so what is polymorphism
um my view of polymorphism was well
because of where I learned it you have a
base class you have derived classes you
have Dynamic binding to figure out which
one to use that's what polymorphism is
that's what I wrote and talked about all
these years and then a year or two ago
something started not feeling right or
maybe not feeling right more and then I
got to the point where it's like oh no
I've met I made a terrible mistake and
that's what led to this talk so
polymorphism is in its Essence a type
that represents multiple types and
usually the way that we see this is in
the form of a function parameter but the
but the purest sense of it is we have a
type and it's represented it represents
multiple types
you might be wondering why would you do
this and we want to keep that question
in mind as we go through here
there's a couple of ways so what we're
doing is we're somehow fitting a group
of types into a single type and there's
a couple of ways to do it one way is to
know ahead of time that that's what you
want to do sort of the waterfall
approach and say all right I will you
know have a base class which is going to
represent my types and I'll have these
derived types and I'll fit them into
this hierarchy and now everything is
polymorphic the other approach which
we're seeing more and more of and we'll
look at here is you can modif you can
have disjoint types that that have no
association with each other and you can
modify the functions so that they can
take more than one type so that's that's
what you'll see here two a couple of uh
two two approaches there are um so the
examples that I'm going to do
demonstrate different forms of
polymorphism some of which you may not
have seen or be be as familiar or
comfortable with and I'm going to show
them to you in different languages and
some of these languages I've written
books about like kotlin I'm I I'm going
to lean more towards kotlin because it
has a very clean syntax and
Java of course not as clean of a syntax
some kind of accumulated a lot of craft
over the years but still what a lot of
people use C plus a few examples in that
Scala of course which has really pushed
Us in the functional Direction and
python I've spent I've had 25 years of
experience with python why I haven't
written a book about it yet is a ongoing
question because it still feels like
it's the language I just am drawn to
um rest and go I've spent hours with and
have gotten some help from friends to
create these examples and in the case of
rust help directly from the rust
compiler telling me try this
um okay so the first kind of most basic
form of polymorphism is called ad hoc
polymorphism I apologize for the the
size of this I'm using a new tool and
probably won't use it again it's okay
but so here we have two functions both
named F or two function calls both named
F but taking different arguments and
this is simply when we Implement these
we see that there are actually two
different functions
so this is you'll see up in the right
corner here the the language that I'm
using on each of the slides this gives
you the path in the repository to that
example so if you want to look it up
that way
so I have uh two classes person and
robot now they're open because kotlin by
default makes all classes final so I'm
going to be using these later and so I
needed to make them open
uh kotlin
you use fund to define a function it's
explicit functions which is more common
these days
there is what I'm using here is the
expression syntax if you have a single
expression that represents your function
you can simply say equals and provide
that expression so it's nice and concise
otherwise if you have multiple
Expressions within a function use curly
braces so notice that this the package
name suggests it
these two classes have nothing to do
with each other and their names function
names are different they're they're
completely separate so from that I can
create
two functions called nourish now they
they're totally separate functions but
they have the same name so that's
function overloading and they take
different types and the compiler says
well if you hand me a person I can call
consume if you hand me a robot I can
call charge and when we call it it looks
like I'm calling the same function but
it's just an overloaded function so the
compiler evaluates this at compile time
there is no Dynamic binding in this case
so this seems like you know pretty when
it first came across to me in C plus
plus it was like oh function overloading
now that seems maybe a little silly but
I can perhaps see the value of it
other languages have overloading Java
there are these are the examples in
their paths python even has
a form of overloading which is in its
single dispatch Library
the second thing is the one that I was
first introduced to polymorphism is
subtype polymorphism or just the Classic
inheritance and dynamic binding and this
in a statically compiled language
requires you to follow this list off
substitution principle which is
you can only call functions that are
defined in the base class or the the
interface
and you can't be tacking functions on in
the derived classes because you're
always up casting to the base type and
calling things through the base type
that's what makes it polymorphic so how
would you even know what those functions
are and contrast that to Small Talk
where everything is it doesn't know
until it receives the message whether it
can actually handle the message very
Dynamic very runtime oriented okay so I
argue well this is a really interesting
thing to observe when you try and
shoehorn the ideas of small talk into
your programming language as Java did
all right so here's another example with
kotlin where I am expressing inheritance
it's what we expect the base class that
or interface in this place okay since I
didn't need to have any implementation
has an eat function and kotlin requires
an override some languages have have
sort of tacted on like Java and C plus
plus and uh I think even Scala has an
optional annotation but if you don't put
it on it doesn't care it helps you if
you add it it doesn't care if you don't
whereas kotlin requires the override
keyword so
person eats Pizza the robot charges and
here is the polymorphic function which
takes the base and calls the common
function that is defined in the base
type and I'll create a list of person
and robot call a four each this is a
Lambda that we pass for each it is a
special keyword in kotlin and it simply
means the current object that we're
working on either the person or the
robot
this pattern here is going to be
repeated through all the different
uh examples so I won't
emphasize that unless it needs to be
all right so the thing ideally you've
seen before the inheritance polymorphism
there's versions in Scala and Java and C
plus plus in Python so it's it's the
most common thing that you see
there's also multiple inheritance or
things that kind of look like multiple
inheritance and what that does is it
takes see in this case in the in the
regular inheritance version I said oh I
know I'm going to be using these in an
inheritance hierarchy so I'll just
design that from the beginning again the
waterfall approach when you know ahead
of time now if somebody hands you some
classes you can't change them one of the
initial approaches and the the
legitimacy for multiple inheritance was
well okay what if we can take our Base
Class and we'll take the person object
and also inherit from base and then
we'll have something that we can treat
as a base
great
um
so what we're doing here is this is the
implementation base is the interface
that we want
and
the thing about this is that we never
really I mean there might be situations
where you want to upcast to a person or
a robot at the same time but by and
large the only reason that you're doing
this is so that it now has a base
interface so the person and robot Parts
we're really just using so that we can
call their consume function and their
charge function
and not that we would ever upcast to
them so
what we're really doing is composition
so we're sticking an object and this is
literally what the compiler is doing for
you it's sticking a person and a robot
object in there and we have the
questionable benefit of not having to
call say if I put a person object
calling person consume explicitly but is
that a benefit or is that kind of
confusing I mean if you if you want in
Python we have a thing that says
explicit is better than implicit in this
case you know if you're reading a lot of
code and you just see consume does that
is that helpful or would it be nicer to
actually see the where that consume is
ending up
so one of the things that we do what the
alternative for inheritance is to
actually put
a person or a robot
explicitly in there and then
there's no question what you're doing
you're calling the consume to reuse the
code from the person object and it's
also much clearer That Bass is what I'm
up casting to I'm never going to upcast
to a person or a robot
all right C plus plus
way back when it was initially being
created I was on the I was one of the
founding members of the C plus standard
committee and was on it for its first
eight years so I watched all this happen
not that I was like the brilliant person
I was more drawn as as somebody who
might be able to explain things
um so for me it was it was kind of like
continuing to go to graduate school
because you were hanging out with all
these super smart people who could
answer your questions okay so
um C plus plus as I said before
everything is private by default until
you put the public keyword in there and
now here's my base so I had these
disjoint types I put my base in with its
eat and C plus plus has this ability to
do private inheritance and so I'm simply
inheriting this for the implementation I
can explicitly never call inherit this I
can never up cast to a person or a robot
and I get the again questionable benefit
of being able to Simply call consume and
charge directly without referring to an
object but did that really help and
there are people who are C plus plus
programmers who have never seen private
inheritance because it's not used very
often it was an experiment that that
people decided yeah that's probably not
what we want to do
all right and then the rest of it is the
same the same idea in a C plus plus form
the next thing that I encountered was
parametric polymorphism generics or in
my case templates in C plus which was
mysterious I kind of shrugged off the
idea that somebody called it
polymorphism because it didn't fit my
model of virtual functions so the idea
of parametric polymorphism is we have
this parameter so now when I have a a
thing called a holder it doesn't just
create one type it creates a whole class
of types depending on what parameter you
put into it so I can have a holder of
cars or a holder of robots or holder of
lists of cars or all sorts of things and
it was initially
intended to support
standard libraries especially standard
container libraries
and that's mostly how it got used
although there are other interesting
things that you can do with generics
which make them more complicated so in
the case of if we if we take a kotlin
example we can see here's our holder of
T and in kotlin if in the class argument
list the Constructor argument list you
have Val or ver it automatically creates
a field for so now we automatically have
a value field
private means that doesn't mean that it
prevents you from passing the argument
but it prevents you from looking at that
it makes that field private
automatically so you have to have some
sort of accessor in order to get it and
in this case
um get and produces the type the exact
type that I put in and that's an
important thing that we'll look at a
little more in a second so here's our
cars and robots so I can make a holder
of cars and a holder of robots and I
have explicitly put the type parameter
here but the compiler when it sees a car
it can figure out that I want a holder
of car so it can do that for you but
there are times as in this case that you
want to make it explicit and notice that
when I call get I get the exact type out
as I put in and that's
that's kind of the key there and
especially when we're dealing with
Erasure so here is something that's a
little closer to what we're talking
about my nourish function takes
something of the type parameter so
one function can accept all different
types
in this case any type at all
and and it when you call it it produces
the exact type as its result
now what can I do with that
well because of Erasure normally you
can't do anything but Java is adding
um
very slowly adding
a pattern matching or some version of
pattern matching and so what we can do
is we can say all right I expect my
subject to be either a person or a robot
and so I can match on that and do the
appropriate things and it does the type
checking and then I can return it but
you're going well I mean you're really
treating this as if it's anything and
you're doing a pattern matching on it do
you really need to print you know add a
type parameter to that you could just
say it's in any
and then the same code works the
difference is when I return this thing
it can only return in any it can't
return the specific type that's really
the essence of on the jvm of generics is
that it's about the return type it's
it's basically the compiler is sticking
an automatic cast in at this point to
return it to the type because it to the
exact type because it knows that's what
it is
all right so
now
um
so so here it's returning nourish is
returning a robot but nourish 2 can only
return in any
that's because of Erasure that's because
they shoehorned the feature in later and
they couldn't you they couldn't do what
C plus does which we'll look at next
um
uh well actually yeah shortly so we'll
see kotlin has introduced what are
called reified generics where it doesn't
erase the type
and
that's gives it a little more power for
situations where you need it
there's something called structural
typing which you're used to seeing in
say languages like Ruby and python has
it which we'll look at first so again
we've got person and robot in this case
they both have eat functions and now we
have a nourish
which takes anything
so it just takes an object takes any
type at all and it basically throws the
eat function at your object and if it
works awesome you've you've passed in
the right type if it doesn't work
gives you an exception at runtime and
there's and there isn't there's no type
checking on this so
python is actually closer to Small Talk
than than anything
um
so okay that's that's interesting and
can be very useful but maybe not
something you'd want to put into a
productive production system unless you
had some some more scaffolding around
that which we'll look at
C plus plus also does structural typing
surprisingly enough since it's
statically typed and that is through
templates
okay and what a template does kind of
like the name sounds when I call nourish
with a person
the template generates it lays down a
new piece of code
and when I call nourish with robot it
lays down another piece of code so it's
basically doing function overloading for
you and the thing is if person or robot
doesn't have whatever function your duct
typing Lee calling
you will find out at compile time
because that overloaded function will
not compile okay so that's that's pretty
cool so this has been around for the
duct typing pre predates it
um kind of the best of all worlds
now here's some new stuff which is Union
types and this is
I think it originally might have I'm not
sure about where it originally came from
could have been Haskell
um
and what you can do is you can create
basically an anonymous type by combining
multiple existing types that are
usually disjoint you can say I I want
you to create a type for me that is
includes the possibility that it might
be type 1 type 2 type 3 or some other
type
so we can see this python has it now I
mean newer versions of python so here
are disjoint types
as we've seen before
and here is
our call to nourish and the way that we
Define a type Union is like that we just
say x can either be a person or a robot
now in the version that I have now one
of the things that
you want to pay attention to is this
idea of exhaustiveness checking you want
your type Checker to say oh hey you've
covered person but you haven't covered
robot or you haven't covered something
here you want it to tell you so that you
know everything
the tools that now there might be one
out there that I haven't looked at but
the tools that I've looked at right now
it's a relatively new feature so they
probably haven't gotten around to
exhaustiveness checking but they
probably will now what happens when I
give it the wrong thing I get an error
at type check time I don't have to
actually exercise the program to
discover the problems so that's a step
forward and
Scala also same oh I'm using Scala 3
here so it looks a lot like python uh
you they don't have the curly braces
um so in Scala with our disjoint types
there it looks almost the same
and we do the pattern match on it and if
I were to leave any of these out it
would the compiler would tell me you you
it's not exhaustive what you've done
isn't exhaustive and the other thing in
Scala is
ordinarily you're used to saying oh I've
got a list of things and the compiler
can go oh you you have a list that is a
person or a robot but it doesn't do that
you have to be explicit when you define
your list you actually have to give it
the necessary hint for it to figure it
out
um
so go also has a version of Union types
goes syntax is a little different
because it separates the structure from
extension functions that you attach to
the structure so this is saying this is
an extension function for the person
struct this would be the argument that
you would use inside of the function
body if you
uh we're going to use it I didn't so I
could have replaced it with an
underscore here it's
the consume and charger capitalized
because that makes them public and uh
that's why go as a simpler language is
because it has fewer keywords and we
know that the number of keywords is the
direct I'm being sarcastic here so
um anyway uh that's and also when you
see the formatting here like sometimes
the formatting is aligned to the curly
brace and sometimes it's not that's go
standard formatting so
whatever you want to take from that
um
yeah
anyway so this is goes
um
template
yeah their parameterized type syntax so
they've got square brackets and as far
as I can tell you have to give it some
information about what that type can be
this is basically as much as I know
about go but you can see that in this
case they're using Union types
all right so let's go C plus plus even
has a union type syntax it's variance
and there's an example in there
it's not pretty
just warning you
now there's also something called
protocols and protocols is another way
to take your types and mash them into
something
and go has protocols so we once again
have our person in robot and we've added
the extension functions to make it work
like objects now those were defined
before now we create this entirely
different interface called eater which
has an eat function and nourish which
takes an eater and calls the eat
function but notice there's no
information about what that is
uh what eater is associated with and so
when you pass something to nourish it's
ch it checks to see that it conforms to
the eater interface
this is this is pretty interesting
um
okay
python has uh kind of protocols
and
now there's something which is a little
newer called algebraic data types and to
move us into that there's we've got
enumerated data types which just not
algebraic data types where we have an
enumeration we can do matches on it and
do different behaviors
okay that's that's pretty interesting
but an algebraic data type so each in
any num what's interesting is that I
don't know maybe through scholar through
Scala 2 Martin oderski was kind of like
enums yeah don't really care that much
about them and then in scholar three
it's like I am all about enums he just
got totally into them and understandably
so the thing an algebraic data type has
to have an argument the these are
automatically case classes so rather
than having only single instances of
ichi num now I can create
my own I can create my own instances of
these things and so that's what's
required for it to be an algebraic data
type but the important thing is that
when you do a pattern match on these
things it's exhaustive the compiler
makes sure that it's exhaustive
uh kotlin has you can do something like
that and there's an example with that
and then
getting into some maybe a little more
esoteric things but still fits with our
idea of polymorphism is type classes
so
with type classes
I have a trait which is called well in
this case it's called eater and it has
the eat like we've seen before this is
an extension on some parameterized type
t
and it gets in implemented for a person
and for a robot and then our nourish
function
notice that I'm passing it just a person
in a robot but there's this second
curried function which a curry parameter
which is automatically included by the
compiler so it's going to look up to see
is there an eater for person is there an
eater for robot and if there is I'll
automatically put that in there for you
so it's basically an adapter which is
taken care of for you by the compiler if
it doesn't exist it says oh there's no
adapter for that
so um this is this this one has taken me
a while to kind of get used to but um
and and there's questions about whether
uh type classes are the great way to go
or not that's still an experiment but
skull is an experimental language so
that's not surprising
rust has its own form of type classes
I'm getting close to uh running out of
time so I'm going to skip through some
of these things there's a there's
something called multiple dispatching
which versions of lisp and Julia has
where instead of dynamically binding on
a single parameter you can do it on
multiple parameters
um
I talked about inheritance for code
review reuse and here's another example
with showing that both rust and go
discourage this they only allow you to
do interface implementation and not
multiple levels of inheritance which I
think languages are going to more and
more start moving towards all right so
why do we want to treat these multiple
types as a single type that should be
the question that that we're asking
we're going through all this trouble to
do it and might be to separate things
that change from things that stay the
same might be to reduce code duplication
but I think it's really about capturing
and reusing Concepts and so you know
making life a little easier for the
programmer to think about rather than
having all these different functions
that do slightly different things but my
point is to understand it don't do it
without questioning I'm going to skip
this
uh and talked about code reuse without
inheritance um the I'd say the um
important thing about this uh code reuse
with inheritance is
that's sort of a thing well my friend
Luciano ramalo said that when you're
doing that you're talking about a
framework you're introducing new later
incorporation of new types and that's
really a framework so if you're solving
a problem just solve the problem and
don't say oh I need an inheritance
hierarchy here but if you're creating a
framework then you go well I want to add
new types later
um
was oh a mistake a lot of people are
saying oh oh it's a total mistake we
should never have done it sometimes it's
quite useful it's just not something
that we should be forced to use all the
time this was one of the mistakes I
think that Java made and
um
and one interesting thing to note as you
learn about functional programming is
that ad hoc polymorphism is used all
over the place
things like map and fold flat map you
know all these functions they're
different implementations for different
situations but they all have the same
name so think about that
um so I uh I had help
and the question since we're out of time
it's uh 12 20. I think uh those of you
have questions let's meet at find me at
lunch and we'll create a table for uh
for discussing this
thank you